cómo superar una crisis cómo puede un
país reinventarse cambiar transformarse
amigos de visual política estas son dos
preguntas que nos habéis hecho bastante
tanto a través de los comentarios aquí
en youtube como a través de mensajes en
facebook y twitter pues bien creo que
podemos decir que la economía
normalmente evoluciona mediante ciclos
esto es una fase de crecimiento más
tarde o más temprano siempre le sigue
una crisis y a esta nueva crisis una
nueva fase de crecimiento y así una y
otra vez suma y sigue
[Música]
por ejemplo desde la segunda guerra
mundial eeuu ha atravesado 11 ciclos
económicos completos esto es con sus
años de crecimiento y sus años de crisis
sin embargo amigos esto no siempre es
tan sencillo a veces salir de una crisis
cuesta mucho muchísimo tanto que pueden
llegar a pasar décadas de tal forma que
incluso un país rico y próspero puede
dejar de serlo porque no penséis que
esto es sólo algo que afecta a los
países emergentes para nada
incluso los países más ricos pueden
sufrir este tipo de crisis tan profundas
generalmente por razones políticas mejor
dicho por malas políticas pero eso sí
amigos incluso de estas situaciones se
puede salir
aquí en visual político lo hemos visto
por ejemplo con el caso de nueva zelanda
que tras pasar una durísima crisis
consiguió por completo darle la vuelta a
la situación
[Música]
pues bien en este vídeo vamos a ver otro
ejemplo por cierto un primo hermano de
nueva zelanda canadá si habéis escuchado
bien sabéis que canadá pudo llegar a
quebrar atentos por cierto al final del
vídeo tenemos un mensaje para todos
vosotros
[Aplausos]
[Música]
canadá es uno de los países más ricos
más libres más prósperos y con más
calidad de vida de todo el planeta
la verdad no importa el ranking que
utilicemos puede ser idea de naciones
unidas- el ranking de corrupción de
transparencia internacional el índice de
libertad humana del instituto fraser o
el índice legatum de prosperidad da
igual en todos ellos canadá se sitúa
siempre entre los primeros puestos pero
este vídeo no va de rankings así que
sólo uno más
en el último ranking recientemente
publicado sobre los mejores países
elaborado por la revista news y la
wharton school canadá aparece como el
segundo mejor país del mundo para vivir
[Música]
y está claro lo hemos visto ya en este
canal canadá amigos es un país que está
de moda de hecho en un pasado vídeo en
una de esas encuestas que solemos poner
al final os preguntamos si os gustaría
vivir una temporada en este país y
sabéis que el 93 por ciento ni más ni
menos que el 93 por ciento respondiste
jce que sí que os encantaría vivir una
temporada en el país del curling es
sirope de arce y la policía montada
[Música]
sin embargo amigos cosas en canadá no
siempre han sido tan alegres hubo un
tiempo en la década de los 60 y
especialmente en los 70 donde todo
estuvo a punto de venirse abajo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el desastre
durante años canadá fue un país muy
parecido a eeuu prácticamente un hermano
gemelo
[Música]
el gobierno era pequeño el país estaba
muy descentralizado y los impuestos
venían a ser similares claro la idea era
competir para atraer inversiones y por
aquel entonces también por cierto
personas de fuera inmigrantes
[Música]
sin embargo amigos todo esto cambió a
finales de los años 60 por así decirlo
en esa época canadá buscó distanciarse
de eeuu y probar con un nuevo modelo
político y económico el gran artífice de
toda esta revolución fue pierre trudeau
si el padre del actual primer ministro
'justin crudo
[Aplausos]
claro que las políticas del padre y del
hijo no son ni mucho menos exactamente
las mismas parece que ya estén trudeau
tomó buena nota pero no nos desviemos
[Música]
el caso es que tu padre gobernó canadá
prácticamente de forma ininterrumpida
entre 1968 y 1984 y lo cierto es que
durante estos 16 años en el poder el
país cambió mucho pero que mucho veréis
trudeau quiso implantar en canadá un
nuevo modelo político que estuviese cómo
decirlo un poco más lejos del
capitalismo de washington y algo más
cerca de la apuesta colectivista del
moscú soviético frente a la mano
invisible de adam smith tiene que haber
una mano visible de políticos cuyo
objetivo sea tener el tipo de sociedad
que es atenta y humana
pierre trudeau de hecho en política
internacional una de las cosas más
conocidas de este personaje fue su
estrecha amistad con fidel castro
en cualquier caso lo cierto es que creo
que podemos decir que se le fue la mano
fruto padre subió mucho los impuestos
multiplicó el gasto público nacional
hizo empresas y como pensaba que todo
eso del comercio y la inversión
internacional era malo por eso de la
competencia pues se dedicó a poner
barreras barreras a quien me recuerda
a new years on information es intenso
porque no es el caso amigos es que por
si no fuera suficiente también hizo que
el banco central le diera la máquina de
imprimir billetes para expandir el
crédito y financiar al gobierno os suena
esa receta
[Música]
pues bien el resultado de todo ello es
que en pocos años que el déficit el
desempleo y la inflación pusieron contra
las cuerdas a todo el país así que claro
cuando en 1984 pierre trudeau dejó el
poder lo hizo con el nivel de
popularidad más bajo de un primer
ministro canadiense en décadas tan sólo
22 de cada 10 canadienses le continuaban
apoyando y en ese momento la verdad es
que los ciudadanos de canadá tuvieron
que tomar una decisión muy importante
[Música]
el cambio
en las elecciones de septiembre de 1984
los conservadores obtuvieron una
victoria aplastante el país parecía
tener claro que no podía seguir por el
camino marcado por true dog
así que dicho y hecho el nuevo primer
ministro brian mulroney quiso dar la
vuelta a la situación y empezó por
estrechar lazos con el presidente ronald
reagan una nueva era había comenzado
durante los siguientes 10 años el
gobierno conservador que hizo bastantes
cosas para mejorar la economía de canadá
bajó los impuestos negoció el nafta es
decir el acuerdo de libre comercio de
norteamérica que une canadá eeuu y
méxico y siguiendo los pasos de margaret
thatcher puso en marcha un ambicioso
plan para privatizar grandes empresas
públicas como por ejemplo air canada o
petro canadá
sin embargo amigos hubo una cosa que no
hizo precisamente lo más difícil y lo
más impopular controlar el gasto público
en 1990 ojo el estado suponía más de la
mitad más de la mitad de la economía los
impuestos seguían siendo muy altos el
déficit público era enorme y la deuda
pública subía como la espuma los
conservadores habían tomado las medidas
por así decirlo más fáciles pero la hora
de la verdad no había demostrado mucho
compromiso así que en las siguientes
elecciones en las de 1993 el partido
liberal el partido de izquierdas de
pierre trudeau volvió a ganar las
elecciones
esta vez ahora sí prometiendo una
auténtica revolución sería capaz del
partido de pierre trudeau de salvar
canadá
[Música]
dados los antecedentes no me negaréis
que era algo difícil pero que muy
difícil de pensar pero amigos esta
ocasión fue diferente el nuevo gobierno
quería cambiar por completo y de una vez
por todas el modelo de canadá y no ya no
querían saber nada de moscú ni del
modelo soviético la idea primordial era
que la calidad de vida no sólo no está
reñida con la economía sino que depende
de ella si se quería ganar calidad de
vida tenían que conseguir que canadá
tuviera una economía fuerte y eso es lo
que hicieron sobre todo de la mano del
ministro de finanzas- paul martin el
auténtico impulsor del cambio
pues bien en los primeros años este
gobierno de izquierdas puso en marcha un
fuerte recorte del gasto público
acabaron con muchas cosas innecesarias y
se ajustaron el cinturón por ejemplo
redujeron con fuerza el gasto militar y
muchas subvenciones a empresas
[Música]
fijaos en tan solo dos años en términos
reales el gasto cayó un 15% el gobierno
bajo ese principio que dice que el
estado no tiene que dedicarse a cosas
que las empresas pueden hacer mejor
continuó con el plan de privatizaciones
llegando a privatizar los ferrocarriles
e incluso el sistema de gestión aérea y
no nos han caído los aviones ni se han
producido más accidentes que en otros
sitios todo lo contrario el sistema de
gestión aérea de canadá es considerado
hoy uno de los mejores del planeta el
caso es que en apenas cuatro años la
situación estaba controlada el gobierno
había pasado de tener un enorme déficit
a superávit atentos a este gráfico
[Música]
por supuesto como os podéis imaginar
estas medidas no fueron fáciles pero los
canadienses parecían tener las cosas muy
pero que muy claras tanto que
sorprendentemente en las elecciones de
1997 el partido liberal el partido de
izquierdas volvió a ganar las
prometiendo ojo aún más austeridad y
también esta vez menos impuestos según
decían amigos su papel era proteger y
dar oportunidades a los más débiles no
derrochar el dinero de todos parece
sensato nos parece atentos a estas
palabras de paul martin en 2003 cuando
hacía un repaso a los 10 años en el
poder tenemos que construir una economía
del siglo 21 en canadá para los
canadienses hemos tenido éxito en los
últimos diez años porque no nos
desviamos de nuestro curso presupuestos
equilibrados una deuda pública de
creciente impuestos más bajos debemos
seguir en ese curso debemos ser un
gobierno comprometido con la rendición
de cuentas un gobierno que trata el
dinero de los contribuyentes como si
fuera tu dinero amigos
revolución significó un auténtico punto
y aparte de la historia de canadá
[Música]
vertical
el cambio que vivió el país en los 80 y
sobre todo en los 90 permitió que la
situación cambiará por completo
canadá pasó de ser considerado por el
mismísimo wall street journal como un
miembro honorario del tercer mundo por
sus problemas con la deuda pública a
convertirse en el país de moda
[Música]
el partido liberal no sólo había
solucionado los problemas sobre todo
había cambiado el modelo de país en los
siguientes años hasta hoy todas las
opciones políticas han apostado por este
modelo de canadá
cojo canadá no es un paraíso fiscal ni
mucho menos pero por ejemplo han
entendido que a las empresas hay que
cuidarlas y no castigarlas fijaos
[Música]
y así es si tenemos en cuenta todos los
impuestos que realmente pagan las
empresas la situación de este país es
muy pero que muy ventajosa de hecho
canadá es uno de los pocos países
desarrollados que llevan casi 20 años
dos décadas reduciendo cada poco tiempo
los impuestos para lograr que el país
sea cada vez más competitivo atentos a
cómo han evolucionado por ejemplo los
impuestos a las empresas
[Música]
y ojo porque esta política ha favorecido
sobre todo a los más débiles los
salarios han crecido con fuerza
canadá es uno de los países que más
inmigrantes reciben y las tasas de
empleo son altas muy altas echemos un
vistazo a este ejemplo
es muy común que en los países existan
instrumentos que permiten que los más
ricos puedan invertir sus fortunas
pagando pocos impuestos por los
beneficios siempre y cuando sigan
invirtiendo ese dinero es lo que por
ejemplo en españa conocemos como en las
sicav
pues bien en canadá no las han prohibido
como proponen por aquí algunos políticos
sino que han hecho algo mejor mucho
mejor han puesto en marcha un
instrumento similar pero para todo el
mundo las cuentas de ahorros libres de
impuestos unas cuentas especiales que
permiten aportar casi cinco mil dólares
por persona y año y que están exentas de
impuestos a los beneficios que se
obtengan es decir que si tienes
beneficios por las inversiones que
realizas no tienes que pagar impuestos
pues amigos seis de cada diez
canadienses utilizan estas cuentas
especialmente los que menos ingresos
tienen no está mal verdad además por si
todo esto no fuera suficiente en los
últimos años canadá también se ha
convertido en un campeón mundial de las
libertades civiles como ya hemos visto
aquí en visual político en algún que
otro vídeo amigos así es como canadá
consiguió escapar de la mayor crisis de
su historia y por cierto como también
ocurrió en nueva zelanda y en australia
las reformas fueron llevadas a cabo por
partidos de izquierdas porque esto no es
una cuestión ni de izquierdas ni de
derechas sino de comprender qué
economía fuerte abierta al mundo y
competitiva es la mejor fórmula para
mejorar la calidad de vida de todos pero
dicho esto tenemos un mensaje para todos
vosotros en los últimos días hemos
superado la barrera mágica de los 500
mil suscriptores más de medio millón de
personas hay países más pequeños bueno
bromas aparte muchísimas gracias por
estar semana tras semana con visual
política muchísimas gracias a esos más
de 500 mil amigos que nos siguen y nos
apoyan todos los días vosotros hacéis
que esto sea posible así que muchísimas
gracias a todos sois los mejores 500.000
suscriptores qué pasaba si no os lo
hubiesen contado hace dos años no nos lo
hubiésemos creído muchas gracias a todos
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]